I suppose I did you give an order to
strike on shaven with chemical weapon
that's Tuesday actually no one had to
investigated what happened that day in
hand shake until that moment as you know
han jihun is under the control of
another front which is a branch of
al-qaeda so the only information the
word have had in this moment is by
published by al-qaeda branch nor had any
other information we don't know if the
whole pictures or video that we've been
seeing are true or fabricated that's why
we asked for investigation to what
happened in - this is the second
al-qaeda sources said that the attack
happened at 6:00 6:30 in the morning
while the Syrian attack in the same area
was at in around noon between 11:30 to
12 so it see they're talking about two
different stories or event so there was
no order to make any attack we don't
have any chemical weapons we give up our
arsenal few years ago even if you have
them we wouldn't use them and we had
never used our chemical Arsenal in our
history so what happened is they as I
said only thought it al Qaeda we cannot
take it seriously but our impression
that the West mainly the United States
is hand in glove with the terrorists
they fabricated the whole story in order
to have a pretext for the attack
it wasn't attacked because of what
happened in ha Ji Hoon it's one event
it's a stage one the play that we saw on
the social networking and on TVs the
propaganda and the stage - with the
military attack that's what we believe
is happening because it's only feel a
few days 2 days 48 hours between the
play and the attacks and no
investigations
no concrete evidence about everything
anything
the only thing were allegations and
propaganda and then strike so where
according to you is responsible about
this allocated a chemical attack the
allegation itself by al-qaeda and also
front so we don't have to investigate
who they announced it it's not the way
control no one else about the attack as
I said it's not me whether it happened
or not because how can you verify a
video you have a lot of fake videos now
and you have the proof that those videos
were faked like the white helmet for
example they are al-qaeda they are not
so fond who shave their beard wore white
hats and appeared as humanitarian heroes
which is not the killed same people were
killing Syrian soldiers and you have the
proof on the internet anyway so the same
thing for that chemical attack we don't
know whether those dead the children
were the kid no honk a horn where they
did at all who committed the attack if
there was attack what the material you
have no information at all nothing at
all not investigated so using its
fabrication definitely our hundred
percent false its application we don't
have Arsenal we're not going to use it
and we have many indications if you
don't have the proof because no one has
concrete evidence for mation or
evidences but you have indications for
example less than two weeks run ten days
before that attack the terrorists were
advancing in many phones including the
suburbs of Damascus and Hama which is
not far from Han Ji Hoon let's suppose
we have this Arsenal and less support
that we had the will to use it why
didn't we use it when we were treating
and they chose for advancing actually
the timing of that attack or alleged
attack was when the Syrian army was
dancing very fast and actually the
terrorists were collapsing so why to use
it if you have it and if I'll do it
why do you is it a bad timing not when
you are in a difficult situation
logically this is for a second if you
want to use it if you have it and if you
want to use it again this is if we
suppose why to use it against civilians
not use it again the terror that we are
fighting third in that area
we don't have army we don't have bottles
we don't have any any any less a object
in Hagia one and it's not strategic area
why to attack it well what do what the
reason military I'm don't talk about
military from me from a military point
of view of course the foundation for us
morally we wouldn't do it if we have it
wouldn't have do it because moral it is
not acceptable we won't have the support
of the public so every indication is
against the whole soil so we can say
that this play that they staged doesn't
hold together the story is not
convincing by any means with the US air
strike term seems to have changed his
position on you and CA and drastically
you have the feeling that you lost what
you call have called a potential partner
I said if it was conditional yeah if
they are serious in fighting terrorists
we're going to be partner and I said not
only Isis whoever wants to fight the
terrorists we are partner
this is the basic basic for us basic
principle let's say actually what has
been proven recently as I said earlier
that they are Hanako handing laws would
those terrorists the United States and
the West they're not serious in fighting
the terrorists and yesterday some of the
assessments were defending Isis they
were saying that Isis doesn't have
chemical weapons they are defending Isis
against the Syrian government and the
Syrian army so actually you cannot talk
about partnership between us
who
against the terrorists and who side the
terrorism and the others who are
supporting explicitly the terrorists